I have nothing to do with it I've been
out of Atlantic City for many years I
think most people know that I've got out
some people would say good timing but I
got out many many years ago and I see
what's happening at Atlantic City's just
too much competition there's too much
pressure from Pennsylvania Maryland and
ultimately everybody's going to do badly
because they're looking at casinos as a
panacea but I left Atlantic City about
eight years ago haven't been involved my
name is on the building and it's one of
those things but Atlantic City is it's a
very sad situation just too much
competition can I never recover from
well they'll change the form of Atlantic
City and something else will happen it
does have one very big advantage it's
sitting on the ocean and you know it's
funny I've always had a lot of great
success on oceans rivers and lakes right
up the road from DC I have a great golf
course a great club called trump
National Golf Club Washington DC and
it's on the Potomac River and anytime
you have something on an ocean a river
or a lake it's really hard to blow it so
I think adil antic City can come back
it's got to use the asset of the
Atlantic Ocean what went wrong I mean
you you well the politicians made
yeah the politicians made many mistakes
in Atlantic City and one of the big
mistakes they built the Convention
Center in the wrong location and I used
to fight them years ago there's many
years ago and it's they just take the
existing Boardwalk Hall and add three
walls in a roof and you have a much
bigger better Center in a good location
they decided to do it their way they
built a convention center in the
absolute wrong location the worst and
then they didn't have hotel rooms and it
was too small then they would have had a
much bigger one for one-third the cost
so after that happened I sort of said to
myself this is ridiculous they don't
want to listen to anybody they made a
lot of mistakes over the years in
Atlantic City but I have a warm spot for
Atlantic City but I'd been gone for many
years in your view has Chris Christie
done enough to try and revitalize it
well he's trying very hard to have you
revitalize it and he's working very hard
he's got some very good people working
on it and it's tough you have tremendous
competition surrounding it and by the
way that competition is starting to eat
away at itself so ultimately the great
panacea which is casinos will not be the
penisy do you regret it all that your
names
the building I think everyone knows that
I've gone Atlantic City was a place that
I really loved you know I did it for a
long time in Atlantic City but a lot of
people say when I left that's when it
went bad and in one way I'm honored by
that statement but in another way I feel
badly about Atlantic City